>> The big question that I think needs to
be answered is how can we
provide entrepreneurial education to poorest
of the poor.
Access to education as we know it is no longer
sufficient or valid,
only access to education but education that
has no quality does not
produce any tangible results.
Many of the world's poor have access to education
and in fact have been
to third, sixth, ninth grade.
That has not changed anything so what they
need is practical
entrepreneurial education to everybody.
In order to to provide this education that
I think that education
should pay for itself or could pay for itself
by income-generating
educational programs on campus with the teachers
and with the students.
But we think that if we do not do something
with quality of education
right now, we will not be able to overcome
the challenges that we're
facing right now.
Thank you very much.